-Welcome to the show!
-Thank you so much
for having me!
-I´m so happy to have you.
This book is fantastic.
It takes place
in Shaker Heights, Ohio,
which is where you´re from.
-Yes.
-It takes place in the ´90s.
Why -- I want to start with why
you chose to put it in the ´90s.
-The first reason was that
it gave me a really good excuse
to relive my teen years,
which is not something
that I ever thought
I would actually say.
-Uh-huh.
-But the real reason is that
I wanted to look at sort of,
how far we´d come
and then how far
we hadn´t come
from race, class,
all of those issues.
I remember living
in Shaker Heights in the ´90s,
and the way that we talked
about race was really to say,
"I don´t see race."
And now that´s sort of
a punch line, right?
And so I wanted to look at the
ways that we haven´t really gone
as far as we think we have.
-Also, just reading it, I
realized, oh, this is nice,
that, in the ´90s, like, the
fact that anyone has
a cellphone is mind-blowing.
And so teenagers communicate
the way it sounds like
you communicated as a teenager.
-Exactly.
So, it was before cell phones,
before any kind of social media,
before the Internet was
even really a thing.
I needed the characters to have
a little bit of space
to have secrets, ´cause these
characters have a lot of things
they´re keeping from each other
and trying to hide
and leave behind parts
of their past.
And it´s a lot harder
to do that now
and I wanted them
to have that space.
-And so you put it
in Shaker Heights,
and this is the town
you grew up in.
But I´m wondering if in
the writing of the book
and the researching in the book,
did you find out new things
about where you were from?
-I did.
I learned way more about the
Shakers, the religious community
that used to own the land
that became Shaker Heights,
than any reasonable person
needs to know.
-Uh-huh.
-So anything you want to know
about the Shakers now,
-I can talk about.
-Yeah, all the --
When you went to the library,
all the Shaker books
were available,
none were checked out?
-They were. The Shaker Heights
Public Library actually has
a really great
local history room,
and this is where local
history librarians do the job
when nobody else can.
She pointed me
to old newspapers,
all kinds of books
about the Shakers
and everything.
But I also learned that a lot
of things that I thought
were normal from growing up
in Shaker Heights were actually
not normal at all --
both good and bad.
-One thing you were talking
about, there´s a --
which I did not realize either.
There´s a Halloween tradition.
And this is sort of --
does this come from the fact
that the Shakers were very
regimented and organized?
-I think it does.
Even though the Shakers were
never actually living
in Shaker Heights, somehow that
kind of rule-following nature
sank into the ground, and
has permeated the community now.
So in Shaker Heights on
Halloween when it´s time
to trick or treat, the city runs
the sirens at the fire station
at 6:00 to let you know
that it´s time to start.
And then they run the sirens
again at 8:00 to tell you that
it´s time to stop
trick or treating.
And I thought
that everybody did that.
-Uh-huh.
-And we didn´t realize
that wasn´t true until --
A good girlfriend of mine
who grew up in Shaker Heights
lived near me and
we both have little kids.
And we were talking to our
husbands who didn´t grow up
in Shaker Heights, and so we
said, "Okay, so when do we --
When does trick
or treating start?"
And our husbands looked at us
and said, "What do mean,
when does it start?
It starts when you
put on the costume
and you go outside
and you ring a doorbell."
And we said,
"Well, when does it end?
Like, when do you stop?"
And they said,
"What do you mean,
when does it end?
It ends when you come home
and stop ringing doorbells."
And my girlfriend
just looked at me and said,
"Well, this is just chaos."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And now I just have to ask,
is there --
For the rest of your life,
your adult life,
when you hear a fire engine,
do you have a Pavlovian candy?
-A little bit.
-Yeah.
I want to go and ring
somebody´s doorbell.
-To the other guy, "I hope
your house isn´t on fire.
Also, can I have a Kit Kat?"
[ Laughter ]
You were actually --
So you´ve been doing readings --
Doing a book tour.
And you were --
You rescheduled, thank you
so much for rescheduling
to be here, but you were going
to read
in Shaker Heights tonight.
-I was.
I was supposed to read in my
hometown where the book is set.
So I hope that they forgive me.
I hope this was
a good enough reason.
-Yes.
I think they will forgive you.
But you also --
You know, you talk about
the people in this town.
Do you have any worries
about that versus any other
reading across the country
that you do?
-A little bit, yeah.
I´m kind of nervous about that,
just because it´s --
It´s a little bit writing --
like writing about a relative
or like writing
about your grandma.
You know, you love them
and you want everybody to see
the good things about them,
but you also know all
their weird habits
and their weird quirks
and you want to kind
of reveal those, too.
-Do you think it´s a good --
If I´m in a Shaker Heights
book club, is this
a good book for us?
-I think so.
I think that the Shaker Heights
population will have a lot
of things to talk about.
I hope they see themselves
in the book, and they also
sort of question, like, "Okay
well, do we mean to do that
or is that just
kind of how we do things?"
-And if there´s a character
that they don´t like,
I bet they´ll see someone else
in the book club
as that character.
-Yeah.
-I don´t think
they´ll see it´s them.
-Yeah.
-It´s my next door neighbor.
That´s definitely Megan.
[ Laughter ]
Your parents were scientists.
Your dad worked at NASA?
-He was a physicist.
-And what did they feel when --
That you have two scientists,
when say you want to be
a writer?
-I think they were
really nervous, but I think
they kind of knew
it was coming because
I was an early reader
and ever since I was a kid
I was the one who was, like,
off in the corner,
drawing little books
and making up stories.
And I used to write plays
and I would make my cousins
perform them.
And so I think they were
nervous, because they just --
This was a world
they didn´t know.
They didn´t know how
to do anything.
And so when I told my mother
that I was going to go
and get a Master of Fine Arts
in Creative Writing, she said,
"Okay."
And then we got off the phone.
And the next day she sent me
an e-mail where she said,
"Okay, I´ve talked to my friend
who is the chair of
the English Department here
at our university."
She was the chair of
the Chemistry Department.
And she said, "He assures me
that a Master of Fine Arts
is a real degree.
[ Laughter ]
And that it qualifies you
to teach writing..."
which she wrote with
a capital "W,"
...and artsy stuff."
And so she was like,
"Okay, this is --
you know, I think you´ll be able
to, you know, buy food
and pay for your rent."
-Well, they were right.
They were right on that account.
And thank you so much
for being here.
-Congratulations on the book.
-Thank you so much.
Celeste Ng, everybody!
Her new book, "Little Fires
Everywhere" is available now.